cpac has begun in texas and it's
dominated by supporters of donald trump
and as the u.s heads into the midterm
elections the confidence of attendees is
palpable their aim made clear in the
conference slogan
headlining the opening day hungarian
prime minister viktor orban a couple of
weeks ago he was accused of giving a
speech that sounded like a nazi by a key
advisor who subsequently resigned but he
clearly relished his reputation as he
spoke of creating an alliance of
christian nations protecting what he
called western civilization i can
already see tomorrow's headlines
far right
european racist and anti-semite
strongman the trojan horse of putin
whole speech at conservative conference
he was received rapturously
it was a great speech yeah why was it so
good man i mean he talked about
different policies and hungary that
worked well for his country and how the
united states can maybe replicate some
of those and how we can work together to
advance the conservative cause he was
excellent makes us want to visit
budapest
the major event at cpac will be on
saturday when donald trump appears
before his followers whether or not he
declares his intention to run for
president in 2024 his speech will be a
reminder of the command he holds over
the republican base
another major theme here the republicans
growing outreach to minority voters
why that shift with the hispanic and i
would say uh other minority communities
including the african-american community
to say i'm going to reject these leftist
policies
it's a measure of the disarray of the
democratic party that the republicans
can appeal to supporters of victor orban
here while hoping for the increased
support of minorities elsewhere
shihabra nancy al-jazeera dallas